[Musique]
sur les marches de l'assemblée sourire
de soulagement pour ces députés les
républicains fraîchement élu car ces
hommes et ces femmes sont des rescapés
en 2017 ils étaient 112 sur la photo
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que 61
personnes a fait cadeau les députés qui
sont élus aujourd'hui ont résisté à tous
les vents sont solides ils sont
déterminés je leur fais une totale
confiance si le bateau les républicains
tong il ne coule pas les nerfs ont
réussi à éviter le naufrage redouté par
tous après le score cataclysmique à la
présidentielle
valérie pécresse qui est donc derrière
le candidat reconquête c'était
évidemment l'un des enjeux de cette
présidentielle valérie pécresse
soeurette autour de 5% les républicains
sont au bord du dépôt de bilan financier
et politique
la droite et le centre
solidement enracinée dans les
territoires ne doivent rien lâcher ne
pas se diviser ne pas renoncer à leur
valeur est mené avec détermination le
combat des législatives qui s'annoncent
les électeurs de droite ont voté
emmanuel macron où marine le pen
plusieurs élus menacent de claquer la
porte du parti pour rejoindre le
président de la république
on est évidemment en danger de mort tous
ceux qui ont fait le calcul cynique
qu'on pouvait faire la démocratie avec
deux forces et bien seront déçus parce
que week-end n'ont pas envie de mourir
et jeudi vont le prouver
mais l air paris sur les législatives
pour faire oublier la catastrophe
présidentielle combien d'entre eux
quitteront le navire d'ici les élections
parviendront-ils à récupérer leurs
électeurs combien de députés ont
verront-ils au parlement les sortants
sauveront-ils leur siège récit d'une
campagne où les républicains ont joué
leur survie
[Musique]
nous sommes dans la 5e circonscription
du vaucluse qui englobe carpentras est
apte ici au premier tour de la
présidentielle marine le pen a fait 22 %
valérie pécresse seulement 4% julien
aubert et le député sortant les
républicains
on va au 69 camion s'agit
en ce début mai il espère bien faire un
troisième mandat bonjour voila j'ai fait
ma campagne ce soir la kasma mon
opération de porte à porte voilà bon des
fois que j'ai particulier pour l'instant
bon on attend dé
moi aussi j'attends de suite bien bon je
peux compter sur vous et vous pouvez
compter sur moi ce gentil un porte à
porte qui ne doit rien au hasard le
député s'est offert quarrata
[Musique]
les points noirs sur les personnes
inscrites sur liste électorale ce
logiciel de cartographie électorale lui
indique les bureaux qui ont voté l air
aux dernières élections je prends
toujours de cartes évidemment qui sont
les quartiers qui sont plus importants
puisqu'il faudrait d'abord rêvé notre
électorat savez les gens de droite ils
sont un peu le peuvent des prix mais
dont le fait d'aller les voir ils disent
bon bah tiens il ya un candidat est lui
passé je vais voter il mise sur son
implantation locale pour effacer le
souvenir de la débâcle à la
présidentielle je le tour du quartier
pour les élections
ne vous inquiétez pas ces gens
koné le pouls des gens des gens ne vous
parle pas de la mairie pécresse il vous
parle pas des présidentielles il parle
de vous et vous disons vous connais vous
inquiétez pas on sera là
pour mobiliser son électorat urbain
il agite aussi le chiffon rouge
j'avais une dame de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique solidaire voilà
nous pèse celle de mélenchon
et tente une petite blague prise au
premier degré il n'y a pas un communiste
permet d' une fois ci et d'un marteau
dans le coin qu'il fallait que j'évite
par hasard
si vous sortez
d'accord
[Musique]
le soir même
dans son village natal au coeur du
luberon
julian verts tient sa première réunion
publique
l'heure est à l'optimisme
le député sortant incarne une ligne
souverainistes au sein des républicains
il ne se sent pas menacé par le
rassemblement national il espère même
récupérer une partie de ses électeurs
je pense que les mêmes qui votait le
paye
c'est facile vendre des bonbons parce
crasse de la
présidentielle la cplp
je suis d'accord c'est ce que je dis aux
journalistes mais je crois je n'ai je le
redis c'est le ils voient les étiquettes
chaude où il vend le bois aux
présidentielles et jean marie le lay a
pas m'arriver
cet art corruption
parce que c'est des vi nations
s'il gagne cette législative ou alençon
il s'en servira comme d'un tremplin pour
reconstruire un parti en lambeaux mon
objectif c'est d'être un jour en
position de changer dans le sens de
visiter les choses je vois des as nous
un mandat vous vous prenez deux fois
plus vous le pouvez intervenir dans les
médias plus vous quand vous rentrez dans
la piscine ça fait des vagues il ya la
présidence des républicains et je crois
être candidat il ya donc je le dis pour
ma génération c'est lé moment quoi les
eu un article aujourd'hui qui sait qu'on
était à génération sacrifiée on peut la
génération pivot julien aubert voit loin
peut-être un peu trop ses ambitions
nationales ne tiendrons que s'il
parvient d'abord à se faire élire député
[Applaudissements]
à l'autre bout du pays dans le lot
aurélien pradié est une autre figure
montante des républicains dans mon jour
désormais numéro trois du parti lui non
plus ne cache pas son envie de peser
plus sur la scène politique nationale
en 2017 à la surprise générale il est
élu député dans ce bastion du parti
radical de gauche ce sont ses électeurs
qu'il faut à nouveau convaincant je
crois
mais il ya du boulot qui a été fait
depuis cinq ans donc il semblerait que
ça commence à se savoir vers là à part
ceux qui sonnent sectaire vous êtes
apprécié il y en a quelques heures
quelques mantovani à bientôt et merci
je réponds parce que ça porte malheur
je le sais à bientôt
mais si les pas des gens de gauche qui
avaient déjà voté pour moi je serais pas
ici ne serait pas élu
pour forcer le destin le député sortant
kadri sa circonscription de village en
village en 4l pour une campagne à
l'ancienne
ça va bien ça va la 4l
nous sommes à quelques kilomètres de
chez lui dans une commune de 2 200
habitants à trois semaines du premier
tour des législatives il enchaîne les
réunions publiques aussi petite soit
elle il s'est pas passé une seule
semaine à l'assemblée nationale durant
cinq ans sans que je rappelle que
j'étais le député du lot parce que je
considère que c'est aussi la première
mission du député de faire entendre son
territoire qui plus est quand cet homme
petit territoire
dans cette campagne les républicains à
l'image d'aurélien pradié insistent sur
leur ancrage local qu'ils brandissent
comme la recette magique pour sauver
leur siège de député mais le lotois
cultive aussi sa différence en
promettant une ligne attentive aux plus
pauvres je suis pour ma part favorable à
ce que sur des produits de la vie
quotidienne on est une garantie de prix
je me souviens à l'époque quand j'avais
proposé ça au niveau national on hurlait
souvient certains de mes amis politiques
qu'ils disaient enfin pour allier est
devenu complètement fou ça y est c'est
un communiste qui veut bloquer les prix
sur les produits j'ai eu droit pendant
des semaines ce qui m'a valu d'ailleurs
d'être souvent traité de communiste de
droite pourquoi envoyer arrive parfois à
faire le grand écart je m'interroge
à ravine creuse sera un communisme de la
communauté d'europe
à fait d'accord et je suis ravi que
ce discours aux accents sociaux qui peut
séduire l'électorat de gauche reste très
éloigné de celui de julien aubert
pourtant membre du même parti c'est bien
je crois le même que julien baer c'est
bien pour lui et puis c'est bien pour
moi il pour un comment évidemment il ya
le point de rassemblement sur la valeur
du travail sur l'idée qu'on se fait de
la république compris je prends sur la
justice à chacun pour le reste la droite
dans laquelle je crois et je crois ne
pas être une somme c'est une droite
populaire c'est une droite qui
s'intéresse aux souffrances et l'humble
à bientôt bonne soirée je vais essayer
de pas renverser la 4l
en vaucluse les républicains espèrent
encore sauver deux de leurs bastions
le député sortant julien aubert fait
campagne pour une droite indépendante
il vaudrait pas mieux faire le marché à
carpentras
parce que les a mis là en quinze jours
j'ai pas foutu les pieds une fois
atteint contrat
pour essayer de le faire tomber la
république en marche investi un maire
bien implanté dans le département on a
une salle principale je pense qu'on est
bien en marche celui qui vote en marche
il peut se dire à la dernière fois le
candidat marche était au second tour 2
le président de la république et gagner
il faut lui donner une majorité donc je
pense qu'il ya une petite dynamique pour
en marche une dynamique qui pourrait
s'amplifier dans les coulisses on
s'agite les conseillers de l'élysée
tente de débaucher des députés aient
l'air pour renforcer leurs troupes
julien aubert reste zen il ne croit pas
à une vague massive de départs avant des
soupçons des douze salopards et
finalement on a à peine de quoi faire
une équipe de volley
je joue je précise qu'on joue au volley
à 6,1 pour ce qui
si ça continue je sais même pas sûrs
braafheid belote
après des semaines de tractations et
d'hésitations quatre députés sortants
quitte le parti et leur constance le
grip député des hauts-de-seine
marine brenier dans les alpes-maritimes
robin ray d'art dont l'essonne et jean
carles grelier dans la sarthe ils sont
juste assez nombreux pour faire une
belote mais pas assez pour faire
s'écrouler le parti gaulliste
pourtant le 20 mai le chef de l'état
tente un dernier coup de poker il fait
entrer un député l air au gouvernement
et pas des moindres monsieur damien abad
ministre des solidarités
de l'autonomie et des personnes
handicapées
cette fois c'est un coup dur pour les
républicains car damien abad et le
président du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale une prise de guerre hautement
symbolique pour emmanuel macron
moi même je mesure la responsabilité qui
est la mienne étant aussi en situation
de handicap
[Applaudissements]
peur est tombé
au bord du lac de nantua dont l'un après
sa nomination nous retrouvons damien
abad
l'ancien président du groupe et l'air
est candidat à un troisième mandat de
député sauf qu'il a changé de camp
moi j'ai toujours été de la droite
modérée et je pense que entre la feuille
de route qui est présenté par le ferait
dans la public et les valeurs et les
convictions de jeunes car il ya une
proximité cette proximité elles existent
avec déjà là ça aurait été une faute
pour moi que de refuser d'entrer dans ce
gouvernement
avec une telle responsabilité sur des
sujets qui m'intéressent comme le
handicap les solidarités le maintien à
domicile ou leur où les ehpad
ses anciens collègues de droite l'accuse
de trahison d'opportunisme damien abad
réplique qu'il ne trouvait plus sa place
au république
c'est le sentiment que je suis allé au
bout de quelque chose le sentiment que
malheureusement une partie de ma famille
politique s'est enfermé dans un anti
macro nisme primaire qui correspond pas
à la réalité de notre électorat et qui
correspond pas à la aux attentes des
français voilà c'est comme ça j'en ai
tiré les conséquences après vous savez
dans l'est républicain il ya aussi des
députés avec qui je suis resté très
proche je suis en contact on pense la
même chose voilà c'est dit républicain
c'est pas un bloc uniforme qui passent
tous la même chose damien abad devait
être un trophée politique pour l'équipe
d' emmanuel macron
cependant rien ne se passe comme prévu
car à peine 24 heures après son arrivée
au gouvernement
c'est un coup de tonnerre
mediapart révèle que damien abad est
accusé de viol par deux femmes
tout juste nommé de l'ancien patron des
députés aient l'air devient encombrant
pour la majorité
il refuse de démissionner et clame son
innocence
[Musique]
je conteste les accusations à mon
encontre avec la plus grande des
fermetés
sur le marché de yona le sujet est dans
tous les esprits
damien abad n'hésite pas à continuer sa
campagne sur le terrain comme si de rien
n'était
le député sorte on espère gagner en
dépit des accusations de viol j'ai pas
de commentaires à faire là-dessus j'ai
déjà apporté les réponses c'est plus
compliqué de faire campagne absolument
pas vous savez les gens me connaissent
savent qui je suis donc tout à fait la
même campagne que j'ai fait il ya cinq
ans que j'ai fait il ya dix ans que j'ai
fait il ya un an pour le département
malgré les accolades damien bad est
moins détendu qu'à l'habitude dont les
allées la sphère suscite une certaine
gêne il y a ceux qui doutent et ceux qui
le soutiennent moi je crois pas du tout
à ces calomnies
déjà concrètement contenu
son handicap c'est possible on est un
peu étonné quand même que ça éclate
maintenant aime pas et femmes j'aime
bien quand même pas le fait de dire tout
ce qu'il a fait pour la population pour
les personnes qui l'a beaucoup aidée
mais c'est vrai que ça influencera quand
même le vote c'est donc vous ne voterez
pas pour lui je ne pense pas
cela n'a pas été le cas de la majorité
des électeurs qui lui ont renouvelé leur
confiance
réélu au second tour avec 58 % des voix
damien abad a réussi à sauver son siège
mais pas son poste de ministre il a été
évincé début juillet suite à une
nouvelle plainte
[Musique]
retour dans le lot
nous amène au président du sénat gérard
larcher vieux routier de la droite vient
soutenir aurélien pradié le jeune loup
fidèle aux républicains j'irai t il
avait tout juste à
des relais h en 3,3 pour notre ami
ils ont retrouvé le sourire
le feuilleton des débauchages semble
terminée alors gérard larcher relativise
désormais pour lui l'enjeu des
législatives et ailleurs il en a pas
tant que ça qu'ils ont quittée la
famille et je dois dire que il ya une
sacrée responsabilité imaginer que
l'opposition ne soit incarné que par la
france soumise ou par le rassemblement
national ce qui ne manquera pas quelque
chose de très profond de démocratie
avec cette virée au marché le sénateur
et le député candidats veulent montrer
que les élèves n'ont pas totalement
disparu du paysage politique national
et pas question de se laisser perturber
par les interpellations gênante
[Rires]
ont fait le tour du maroc ont fait le
tour du marché
sûrement
pour réveiller leur électorat le duo ne
rate pas une occasion d'insister sur les
fondamentaux de la droite eh bien ça va
penser à l'hôtellerie oui je l'espère g
sabia personnes mangent et est un
vecteur les épandeurs et ce alors pas du
tout du tout on se bat sur ça c'est
dramatique puisque les gens veulent pas
y aller mais ils seront indemnisés de
l'autre auteur de comment machination et
de travail
qu'on n'aura pas réglé ça on aura les
nerfs prêtons de pouvoir peser encore un
peu sur l'avenir du pays pour y parvenir
ils doivent obtenir un meilleur score
aux législatives qu'à la présidentielle
au soir du premier tour des législatives
dès la clôture des bureaux de vote
julien baer et son équipe s'enferment
dans le quartier général du candidat
contre toute attente les premières
estimations sont très mauvaises
[Musique]
bon ça c'est toi l'ordre
exemple
enfin
25 à 24 one 2
tu vois
mes chances que je sois souvent toi
je récupère 7 points j'ai pas trop
la lys est mort
voilà dont les résultats se confirment
alors qu'il espérait décrocher un
troisième mandat il est éliminé dès le
premier tour c'est évidemment un peu
difficile quand vous êtes remercier
placé en quatrième position voilà c'est
la dure loi de la politique qu'est ce
que vous allez faire vous continuer la
politique vous savez
elle m'a quittée il y a il y a dix
minutes ça fait réfléchir vous dit
finalement si le travail ne paie pas s'y
être 7e députés d'opposition de paie pas
faire quarante mille kilomètres par an
pour aller vers les gens ne paient pas
alors voilà je ne sais pas faire
autrement je ne peux pas être un député
qui reste en sirotant un verre de
limonade à la terrasse je sais pas faire
c'est pas ça que je veux être et donc
effectivement la question se pose pour
l'avenir mais je suis encore jeune du
mercier le verdict est sévère son
adversaire la république en marche est
en tête talonnée par la concurrente du
rassemblement national même la candidate
de la nuque baisse devant julien aubert
oui maputo annoncé
son envie de pleurer non mais t'as et la
maison sur le monde ses droits si je me
retourne je m'en vais on voulait en fait
ce qu'elle ira que serait devenue
présidence il avait abandonné la
première défaite
julien aubert n'a désormais plus aucun
mandat politique
il ne peut que constater que l'étiquette
et l'air ne fait plus recette mon côté
ça encore moi je crois que l'électorat
de droite est désorienté aujourd'hui il
a eu peur de la nuit baisse il sait il
sait pas comment contre emmanuel macron
certains ont voté pour reconquête pour
les rênes notre part et voter et je
crois qu'à la fin tout ceci fait le jeu
effectivement du président parce qu'ils
doivent se frotter les mains aujourd'hui
avec cette défaite inattendue julien
aubert enterre ses ambitions nationales
mais il ne perd pas son sens de l'humour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à cahors c'est jour de fête pour
aurélien pradié
suis ambitieux numéro trois des
républicains a parfaitement négocié le
virage des législatives il est reine
député haut la main
oui
il réitère donc son exploit de 2017
arbon site e
les bâtiments faisait
mais voilà pensé que c'était une
anomalie c'est pas une anomalie ça s'est
reproduit merci aux lotoises et aux
lotois c'est un sport magnifique scène
confiance formidable et si les femmes et
les hommes puis monsieur depuis des
années voilà ça fait quelque chose
malgré une circonscription plutôt à
gauche et un contexte très défavorable
pour les l air il fait encore mieux
qu'il ya cinq ans
nous avons gagné aujourd'hui avec 65% de
la confiance des lotoises et les lotois
nous avons une aventure lotoise à
poursuivre et nous avons une belle
aventure à mener pour notre pays
une victoire confortable qui le conduit
une nouvelle fois à l'assemblée est
peut-être plus loin aurélien pradié
compte bien jouer un rôle de premier
plan dans la reconstruction de son parti
le message que j'ai porté à un niveau
national d'une droite populaire d'une
droite capable de s'intéresser à des
sujets qui n'intéressait plus personne
le handicap l'écologie pourtant sa
famille politique en tous les cas ça
n'intéressait plus ça a fonctionné s'ils
ne changent pas les républicains n'ont
pas d'avenir il faut qu'ils changent de
fond en comble le chemin identitaire
c'est pas un chemin c'est pas un chemin
parce que d'abord sont pas les valeurs
auxquelles je crois et puis c'est pas un
chemin électorale on le voit on
dégringole petit à petit
d'ailleurs beaucoup de candidats qui ont
porté ce ce message identitaires ont été
battus
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au lendemain des législatives
l'assemblée nationale offre un tout
autre visage les français ont créé la
surprise ils n'ont pas donné de majorité
absolue au chef de l'état les
républicains eux évitent la catastrophe
les oiseaux de mauvaises augures leur
promettait une trentaine de députés il
on conserve une soixantaine mais eux qui
était jusqu'à lors la première force
d'opposition sont relégués au troisième
rang derrière le rassemblement national
et la france insoumise il leur faut
désormais trouver leur place
on a une difficulté comment est ce qu'on
arrive à ne pas se mêler
au projet politique d' emmanuel macron
papa réflexe sectaire mais parce que je
suis absolument persuadé que si on joue
ce jeu de l'effacement les clivages on
va encore plus loin dans le désastre
démocratique que nous connaissons et
dans la perte de repères
premier enjeu c'est dans le chaos
d'incarner un repère et deuxième enjeu
c'est de ne pas être des bloqueurs de ne
pas être ceux qui vont aborder lisez
l'assemblée nationale de ne pas être
ceux qui au delà de bordés lisez
l'assemblée nationale veulent affaiblir
les institutions de la vème rennes s'est
il faut pas s'y tromper mais derrière
les altitudes de jean luc mélenchon se
cache en vérité une vraie volonté de
déstabiliser notre extension ses 30 ans
à qui la faute de majorité absolue
emmanuel macron leur a proposé une
coalition que les républicains ont
refusé mais ils savent que leur foi
seront capitales pour voter les lois
nous sommes un groupe d'opposition mais
nous entendons profiter de la situation
de la configuration étonnante de
l'assemblée pour un groupe d'opposition
qui défend qui se bat pour obtenir des
avancées pour les français le groupe ait
l'air jours at il vraiment un rôle
déterminant
tous les députés resteront-ils sur la
même ligne les premiers mois de ce
nouveau quinquennat seront décisifs pour
le destin des républiques
[Musique]